que manon breton élu rural et membres
des constituants bonsoir un nom breton
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france à
quelle est votre réaction vous à
l'imposition de cette circulaire est ce
plafond finalement de 9000 habitants
dans les communes pour effacer la
l'étiquette politique des candidats j'ai
été comme beaucoup de français je crois
aujourd'hui assez enfin aujourd'hui
c'est ressorti aujourd'hui dans
l'actualité mais c'était annoncé depuis
quelques temps déjà assez choquée par le
procédé
puisqu'on voit bien effectivement
comment la république en marge de cette
façon va ripoliné sont son résultat au
moment des élections municipales
on sait bien que les élections
municipales qui interviennent donc dans
deux mois c'est très très tard pour
modifier les règles du jeu de cette
façon là et donc dans deux mois la
république en marche peut craindre
évidemment que cette longue séquence
extrêmement douloureuse dont on sait pas
très bien où elle en sera au moment des
élections puisque la mobilisation vous
l'avez dit n'est pas terminé mais cette
séquence de la réforme menée à marche
forcée pour casser les retraites des
français
on voit bien que personne n'en veut les
français la rejettent massivement ils
soutiennent de plus en plus nettement
les grévistes et tous ceux qui sont
mobilisés
physiquement dans cette dans cette lutte
acharnée et donc évidemment le
d'échéance électorale des municipales
sera naturellement un moment où la
république en marche sera sanctionné
pour cette cette méthode extrêmement
brutale et brutal on le sait y compris
dans la façon dont les les grévistes et
les manifestants sont molestés
physiquement et dont le maintien de
l'ordre étaient effectués de façon assez
inédite dans notre pays voilà donc je
crois que c'est un procédé qui est
extrêmement grossier qui sur le plan
démocratique choque beaucoup de monde et
avec raison
alors vous dites choque beaucoup de
monde c'est pas le cas de l'association
des verts 2
puisque certains élus avaient réclamé
justement cette mesure qui existait déjà
puisqu'elle était appliquée aux communes
de plus de 1000 habitants ils ont
simplement mis un plafond de 9000 9000
habitants
quel impact selon vous pour la
république en marche c'est le manque
d'implantation locale qu'elle assure
chercher à dissimuler
alors en fait jusque là ça existait déjà
moi par exemple chez lui dans un village
de moins de 100 habitants est
effectivement en dessous de 1000
habitants on n'était pas tenus de
déclarer une couleur politique
l'association des maires de france
réclamé que ce soit augmenté à 3500
habitants et voyez que le choix qui a
été fait de monter à 9000 habitants en
soi interroge quand bien même on serait
d'accord avec le fait d'accéder à la
demande des maires de france
eh bien je joue on se demande pourquoi
passer non pas à 3500 mais à 9000 comme
ça a été fait est en réalité la réponse
vient très vite c'est que ils ont fait
un petit calcul et ils ont constaté que
dans les villes de plus de 9000
habitants il avait de bonnes chances
d'avoir leurs meilleurs résultats et
donc d'avoir un état moins
catastrophique peu en prenant l'ensemble
des résultats
or la france qui se trouve gommer de
rayer de la carte du jour au lendemain
de cette façon là c'est justement la
france qui est la plus remontés contre
emmanuel macron et contre sa politique
c'est d'un étang c'est la france des
ronds points c'est celle des qui s'est
mobilisé depuis un an avec le mouvement
des gilet jaune celles qui souffrent au
quotidien de ceux trouvés isolés dans
cette danse avec tous les problèmes
qu'on rencontre lorsqu'on est dans des
zones rurales ou très rurale c'est comme
c'est mon cas et nice et une passe ont
un peu grossière de nous évacuer de la
carte
finalement monsieur macro et les siens
monsieur castanet en l'occurrence
restent ce qu'ils sont c'est à dire des
spécialistes des des bidouillages qui
finalement ne renouvelle absolument pas
les façons de faire
en politique par contre ils y font de
façon beaucoup plus grossières encore
que leurs prédécesseurs ça c'est certain
gérard larcher le président du sénat a
parlé d'un déni de démocratie quasiment
vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui moi je
pense qu'on peut tout à fait le voir de
cette façon là dans la mesure où ça
c'est un calcul vraiment chiffrés qui
vise à augmenter de façon totalement
artificielle les chiffres de le soir du
résultat au 20 heures on aura des
chiffres qui sont beaucoup plus élevés
que si on avait pris en compte
l'ensemble des communes de france on a
quand même on supprime de cette façon là
enfin c'est 96 % des communes en france
qui seront évacués et un électeur sur
deux qui ne sera pas comptabilisé vous
savez mark twain disaient les chiffres
ne mentent pas mais les menteurs adore
les chiffres on voit bien comment ici
ses airs mensonge grossier qui s'appuie
sur une manipulation évidente
merci beaucoup maintenant le breton vous
parlez du 20h le 20h de rt france
évidemment on y sera merci beaucoup pour
votre animal